moving on and lebanon's caretaker prime
minister has warned that renewed
fighting in a Palestinian refugee camp
doesn't serve their cause and also harms
the Lebanese state
najib Makati had talks with the
Palestinian president Mahmoud Abbas
following Street battles in NL Haworth
between rival factions five people were
killed and dozens injured as a ceasefire
between Palestinian armed groups ended
on Friday
is near the southern city of sidon it's
the largest Palestinian refugee camp in
Lebanon nearly 55 000 refugees are in NL
Howe it's one of 12 camps in Lebanon
four Palestinian refugees which were
established back in 1948 after the
creation of Israel rival factions have
long fought for control and the densely
populated Camp an agreement dating back
to 1969 prevents the Lebanese Army from
going into the camp in order to restore
Law and Order well let's speak to Zain
she's near en alkalwa for us zaina there
have been multiple incidents there in
the last few days talk us through what's
behind this rise intention
thank you
well outbreaks of violence are not
uncommon we've seen this time and time
again in recent years there's
lawlessness in the camp Palestinian
factions are armed a lot of criminals
wanted by the Lebanese State hide in
einel Halloween as you mentioned the
Lebanese Army is not allowed to operate
inside the camp the security security
Affairs is run by a joint Palestinian
faction but the latest outbreak of
violence sparked was sparked about a
month ago when a senior commander of the
Palestinian fatah movement was
assassinated now fatah believes he was
assassinated by a group known as the
Muslim youth a number of armed groups
and they are demanding that eight
suspects be handed over to the Lebanese
Judiciary in order to face Justice the
Muslim use is refusing to do that and
that's why there was a truce for
approximately a few weeks while
investigations were underway but now it
seems there is a decision for an all out
confrontation what we understand from
fatah officials is that they will not
back down they are accusing the Muslim
use of trying to take control of the
camp right now fatah is the dominant
faction so they're accusing the Muslim
use of trying to push them out and take
control of the camp they're saying this
will not happen you can hear the the
sound of gunfire clashes have been
Fierce and over the past three days as I
know we know amid these clashes some
people have fled the camp do we know how
they're doing
come on
well yes we are at one of the entrances
of the camp and I'm sure you're seeing
behind me a study stream of Palestinian
refugees making their way out they tell
us they're tired they can no longer stay
inside first of all because of the
fighting Bombshells machine gun fire
sniper fire they're being fired
indiscriminately and landing in people's
homes there have been people who have
been wounded so they're they're making
their way out but they don't know what
to do these are poor people ninety
percent of Palestinian refugees live in
poverty if they do not work today they
cannot put food on the table and there's
still not enough places for them to go
there are a number of schools that are
and a mosque that are being open but
still not enough to house all these
people and yesterday there was an
attempt by the Red Cross to set up tents
and the people here refused they said no
what are you doing you're reminding us
of 1948 when we were first displaced
following the crazy nation of the state
of Israel so they refuse to live in
tents because for them when they see
tense it means that you know they may
never come back home to their Camp even
even though life inside the camp has
been one of misery these are tens of
thousands of people who are now trapped
inside a war zone a woman told me that
they can't find enough food we've seen
people buy bread from nearby bakeries to
go back into
you can hear how Fierce these clashes
are so people really trapped in a war
zone
indeed
how correspondence at the entrance one
of the entrances to en al-halwa Camp
thank you so much then and do stay safe
yourself